the small county in north florida is
mourning the loss of two sheriff's
deputies in a double murder
officials say a gunman ambushed the
officers yesterday that while they were
just sitting and having lunch 29 year
old Sergeant Noel Ramirez and 25 year
old deputy Taylor Lindsay and the man
who apparently shot them were all found
dead at the scene
Don Dahler is here with the
investigation of this still unexplained
attack Don a lot of questions here a bit
more a lot of questions good morning the
Gilchrist County Sheriff's Office's has
only 27 deputies
so the loss of these two officers is
deeply felt the sheriff describes their
County as a family and says they will
honor the fallen deputies by doing what
they do best serving and protecting
their community sergeant Ramirez and
deputy Lindsay were the best of the best
sheriff Bobby Schultz was emotional as
he reflected on the fallen officers if
you ever seen sergeant Ramirez smile
infectious they don't need to be
remembered
strictly further and timely death but
they need to remember the type of people
that they are Sergeant Noel Ramirez and
deputy Taylor Lindsay were eating lunch
at a Chinese restaurant in downtown
Trenton Florida when police say John
Hubert high note fired at them through a
window deputies arrived at the scene to
find the officers dead inside the
restaurant and the suspect dead outside
the sheriff called the alleged gunman a
coward but would not say how he died
what do you expect happens when you
demonize law enforcement to the extent
that has been demonized the sheriff says
the motive is unclear but thinks they
were targeted because of their uniforms
the only thing these men were guilty of
was wanting to protect you and me I can
sit here in front of all of you and tell
you that I love them and I'm proud to
have been there Sheriff sergeant Ramirez
leaves behind a wife and two young
children deputy Lindsay leaves behind a
girlfriend officers haven't said much
about the alleged gunman but we know he
has a criminal history dating back to
1978 when he was charged with carrying a
concealed firearm that case was
dismissed state officials are supporting
Gilchrist County with protective patrols
as they investigate this attack and you
were telling us during the during the
the piece that they never stood a chance
would which makes it even more egregious
that they could have been killed just
because they were wearing a uniform yeah
we don't know if there's any kind of
connection between the officers and the
man who killed them at all yeah
senseless thank you dodged and a
reminder of the bravery what it takes
just when you put on the uniform that's
right